okay today I'm going to talk to you
about root hair cells and stomata these
are two different specialized features
of plants that allow them to perform
certain functions so first of all we're
going to look at root hair cells so here
is a plant if we were to look very
closely at the roots of a plant we'd see
that there are millions and millions of
these tiny little hairs now just one of
those is one root hair cell so I'm going
to draw the structure of a root hair
cell right here okay so this here is a
root hair cell now the whole point the
whole purpose of the roots of a plant is
for absorption of important substances
for the plan so we're going to look at a
couple now the reason why we hair cells
have this long protrusion here is in
order to have a large surface area by
having millions of these little hairs
all with these protrusions like this all
of these yeah like this it means there's
a large surface area for lots and lots
of absorption now there's two main
things that the plant needs to absorb
first of all water by the process of
osmosis and secondly minerals via the
process of active transport so due to
the shape of the root hair cell it
allows maximum surface area which means
a maximum rate of absorption of these
useful things that are needed for the
plants so let's move on to stomata so
stomata are not found in the roots like
root hair cells they are found in the
leaves and in particularly the underside
of the leaf right here stomata
essentially little holes or pores in the
bottom of the leaf and I'll show you how
it works so first of all I'm going to
show you when the stomata are open by
drawing this like this so what I'm
drawing right now
is an open stem at O and I'll show you
what it is in a minute so the middle
part here is where we have the hole so
we have one stoma many mr. Motta so it's
literally just a hole in between these
two cells right next to it I'm going to
draw when the hole is closed when the
this when they're yet when they're
closed so here this time these two cells
mean there's there's no steigler there's
no hole at all okay now these cells are
called guard cells and the guard cells
go either side of the stoma now so why
is sometimes they having why sometimes
is it open and sometimes as it closed
these will be showing that it's open
this one closed now the reason is when
this becomes full of water these cells
become full of water the guard cells
they become turgid now this opens up the
stoma so when they become turgid it
opens up a gap between them called a
stoma and this is useful because
different things can diffuse in and out
of the leaf for example carbon dioxide
water vapor and oxygen they can diffuse
in and out now when there's a lack of
water within the plant the guard cells
become flaccid now because they are
flaccid it means they are now closed if
there are closed these cards these
different substances can't diffuse in
and out anymore because they are now
closed they can't diffuse in and out of
the leaf these stomata
are always closed during the nights
so those are just two different features
root hair cells they have a large
surface area that absorbed that are
involved in absorbing water and minerals
and stomata which are little holes in
the bottom of the leaf that open when
there turgid closed when they're flaccid
and allowed these substances out stomata
allow water vapor out during
transpiration which then leads for the
rest of the water to be drawn up through
thank you